allez peter ah oui toi c'est émouvant de
voir autant de nouveaux visages ici
aujourd'hui je suis sûr que ma mère
aurait été très touché et probablement
un peu étonné ma mère était une femme
très secrète et réservée
[Musique]
ces grands-mères tu sais que tu t'es sa
préférée up était bébé elle ne voulait
pas que je te donne le sein elle voulait
le faire à ma place
c'était une femme extrêmement difficile
ce qui doit expliquer mon caractère
vous êtes le portrait craché de votre
mère quoi je vous jure que parfois je
sens sa présence dans la chambre
[Applaudissements]
elle est toujours là
elle avait des rituels secret des amis
secret
keira s'occupait de moi tu penses que je
vais pas m'occuper de tout mais quand tu
seras marque
elle n'avait plus toute sa tête à la fin
[Musique]
maman je peux sympa j'aime pas satisfait
servi tu peux parler pour ceux dont je
sais pas mais
je ne veux pas rajouter de stress à ma
famille